welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul got some crazy crazy
crazy announcement that's coming in
um so last night and Ellie got arrested
because I broke into some guy's house
but it was fine because that because I
said look was forming a team so yeah you
might be able to hear this guys
unmistakable laugher in the background
but um yeah just to make things a bit
more formal if you've been watching the
channel the last couple of weeks um you
might have noticed that there's there's
a new guy who's joined us
um and yeah we just want to make an
official announcement make an official
fish official video uh Mt welcome to the
channel you are now part of the heavy
spoilers team officially I'm so happy
um I've watched you for years and years
always Blown Away by your videos a bit
annoyed now because
when when they get posted up I'm like
all the comments are like oh empty is
much better than Paul I'm like oh
Paul is amazing
[Music]
amazing
those are you oh my boss yeah
um they've got a minor
yeah so he did the Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3
um video that was kind of what we we
because I just always wanted to see your
thoughts on Guardians of the Galaxy vol
um because I know you're a massive fan
of that series and you did an incredible
job and then across the spider verse
Blown Away by it made me look made me
look at the movie in a totally different
way
gave me a lot of imposter syndrome
thinking oh Jesus I didn't spot that
um and it's 37 minutes long enough about
it anywhere brilliant job
um but yeah more than happy to have you
on board we're so we're so we feel so
lucky to be honest um you know it's kind
of come out of a negative thing right
yeah we're not gonna go too far into it
new rock stars kind of decided to change
up their team and then we just you know
we reached out straight away and we're
like do you want to come do some stuff
for us
um it's not a beef with new rock stars
or anything I've spoken to some people
on the channel
um behind the scenes and they're more
than happy that they really seem over
the moon that you've you've kind of come
over to us and I think I think you're
going to be a really good fit and so
thanks so much for joining us
um and just tell us what you've got
coming out and if there's anything you
want to talk about because I realize I'm
hogging the mic and people probably want
to hear from you instead no no no like
this has been like this is a massive
honor like I've your channel is
incredible you put out some amazing
analysis and like you are literally one
of the best in the breakdown just comic
book Thank You production game so like
when you asked me to join I was like bro
are you serious like are you for real
like is this happening so like no thank
you like this is so exciting I cannot
wait to start
um but yeah no like I'm just like right
now I'm working on a Watchman breakdown
the ultimate cut which is a very big boy
that's a big boy of a of a of a cut but
it's it's so good and like Zack Snyder
put a lot of like effort to recreate
that comic pretty closely
um so like um this is really fun to find
all those details that he hid so yeah
like that's gonna come out soon and uh
more to come like I can't wait to yeah
do more like do a collab video with you
like that'd be so freaking great
yeah no we've got we've talked about
loads of different video ideas I think
you guys are really really gonna love
them
um we're gonna Branch off into different
things as well for example you know
Spider-Man 2's coming out because we
want to we feel like we want to talk
about that
um and just having an extra person on
board you know it's gonna make it so
that one of us can go play games whilst
the other ones doing work
um but yeah just I mean like I haven't
had a break for for ages now I took one
a smaller one back in June and but I've
actually managed to have the last week
off for my birthday as well which really
meant a lot to me yeah
thank you
yeah and that's just because you produce
those two incredible breakdowns that I
could be like oh I can you know there's
a way off my shoulders I can give this
to the editor as Stephen and Matt and
they can work on that and I can just
genuinely just been able to switch off
um and it's and just knowing that you do
an incredible work I mean all the all
the comments as well they're so positive
too positive
yeah and I just I think everyone's you
know really enthusiastic I think um I
think you're gonna do brilliant here and
we're so happy to have you on board we
uh dude I am [__] over the mood oh
sorry I it's okay to swear right
yeah
slide this one time you're not fired yet
whatever let's slide
no I have like literally over the moon
like it's your first date yeah it's such
a great
um just just collaboration man like this
is gonna be so huge like people are so
excited it's making me excited like
we're all just feeding into each other's
hype right now and I'm just like yes
this is the best yeah and I think just
your observation skills as well you're
just gonna bring so much to the channel
that I'd not even noticed and yeah just
the two videos you've done so far have
been absolutely incredible
um you came out the gate swinging you
know I I said that first Guardian to
unlike oh you know do it do it as best
you can and you you actually like over
delivered on it and I was blown away by
how good it was
um yeah just so so happy to have you on
board not saying that the the across the
spider verse one was in Greg because
that was great too but yeah you really
honestly you've uh I mean you can tell
you're a pro straight away from it and
uh you've done such an incredible job so
we're more than happy to have you at the
channel if you're very very lucky that
you've uh said yes to us and we
appreciate it and I love you so much
thank you for joining heavy spoilers
yeah no brilliant
yeah exactly everyone you know very
positive news for us major announcement
we'll put it on a thumbnail put a bit of
mystery on the thumbnails the mystery
didn't hold up for long but we're very
happy uh to have you on board and yeah
thanks a lot guys for all your support
you know you guys supporting the channel
as well means that we can you know it's
not I'm not like a guy with 100
subscribers being like come on Mt come
work for me instead you know it just
just having us out there you know all
your support helps to push the channel
to New Opportunities and get new people
involved in that we really really
appreciate it thank you guys so much I
know Mt loves it as well and he can't
wait to
like all the comments all like your
guys's like support fuel me to want me
to do more it feels both of us so like
thank you so much for all of your your
kindness you guys are amazing
yeah we love you guys and uh yeah hope
you hope you're ready for a big Watchman
video which started off I said don't do
the two-hour cut you're doing the three
and a half hour one
okay okay I didn't know so that's coming
soon obviously lots of Osaka coverage
coming up um I know you're a big
Invincible fan as well oh yes Spider-Man
yes it's gonna be a busy couple of
months guys the boys spin-off gen v as
well you know oh God yes I almost forgot
about that this show looks so good yeah
Loki as well Loki season two so I mean
it's gonna be a crazy time at the
channel and we're of course continuing
with the classic movie breakdowns um
which you know are really they uh the
start of the year I kind of got to a
point where I was like oh I'm getting a
bit bored of talking about the same
being every single week
um and these are really like
reinvigorated my love for talking about
film and and breaking stuff down and and
thank you guys for all your support on
that and I know Mt you know we've spoke
to you about it as well any films old
school ones that you want to break down
more than happy to have you jump in and
just talk about something from like the
1960s or something oh geez all right I'm
work yeah I'm working on 2001 A Space
Odyssey at the moment and I realized it
was 55 years old and I was like oh crap
1968. that's like it might be might have
aged myself oh for this audience that
I've been building but yeah can't wait
for you guys to see it and yeah thanks
so much for joining us on this journey
that will continue with empty on board
[Music]
you guys bye guys